bonjour alain sagna
merci beaucoup d'être bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être en direct avec nous ce
matin sur rtl france l'afrique du sud
qui a détecté ce variant omicron depuis
le pays vit sous cloche comment le
vivez-vous
bon comme vous l'avait annoncé
la population est très mécontent du fait
que les vols sont bannis c'est la rolls
saison touristique vous savez ce sont
les bakas les grandes vacances d'été
chez arrow sartenais les centaines de
milliers les touristes d'avenir de
l'europe
maintenant les wolton ayant été
interrompues comme ça va affecter
l'économie du pays
le nombre de cas a augmenté ou endaka
troupe des quatre minutes par jour le
nombre de décès est très faible une
vingtaine par jour
selon les mots du président il n'y a pas
de raison de paniquer vous en tant que
médecin vous le rejoignez qu'est ce
qu'on sait aujourd'hui de de ce variant
au micro on dit très contagieux l'air
il semblerait que ça très contagieux
mais beaucoup moins dangereux
1 serait plus ou moins les mêmes de
congestion et cetera là tout perdre un
de goût de loder a les symptômes
classiques mais comme je vous ai dit le
nombre de décès démission est faible le
moment donc vous dépasserez d'une
augmentation
vous déploré l'attitude des pays qui
renforcent leurs restrictions justement
sanitaire est ce que pour vous ils en
font trop
bah oui parce que on a découvert des cas
avec le même virus le même variante à
eau en écosse je crois que l'on découvre
des cas en hollande où aussi jodie
découvert à voir l'arrivée des touristes
une africain il ya quelques jours
donc ces virus a été découvert en
afrique du sud mais n'aime pas
sud-africain exclusivement donc c'est
une décision de dépressivité que des
malencontreuse il arrive à un très
mauvais moment du coup afrique du sud a
aujourd'hui le sentiment d'avoir été
puni pour avoir été transparente
exactement d'ailleurs les chercheurs
cela fait gars ont décidé qu'ils ne
partageront plus leurs informations cela
recherches jusqu'à ce que les vols
soient rétablies
donc c'est ça peut ça peut être
problématique on le sait la ono virus
vous l'avez dit maintenant et dans
plusieurs pays donc finalement ça sert à
ça sert plus à rien de fermer les
frontières
exactement vous avez vous l'avez dit
vous-même absolument oui ça fait ça fait
presque deux armes ça dure on voit les
résultats
rien n'a changé pas grand chose a changé
est ce que l'afrique du sud en quarts de
finale en termes de vaccination puisque
ça semblerait être un rempart quand même
contre une contre des formes graves est
ce que en termes de vaccination elle est
satisfaisante en afrique du sud
le dos est basse et 25 pour ça la
population a été vaccinée
il ya une très grande résistance à la
vaccination
dans la population pour le moment mais
bon je pense que les gens commencent à
se faire vacciner
le booster n'est pas encore
[Musique]
légalisé sauf que sauf que pour le
personnel médical
finalement comment est ce que vous
comprenez aujourd'hui cette psychose
dans laquelle nous sommes tombés avec
ces nouveaux variants
je parte une grande panique
vous voyez ce qui se passe en allemagne
le nombre de cas est exponentielle je
crois qu'ils grimpent en france james à
grains partout dans le monde
on doit peut-être changer de ont tenté
de changer d'approché passe parce qu'il
n'y a pas autant de morts qu'avant c'est
surtout ça la clé
n'ont pour le moment pas du tout de tous
les décès est très bas malgré le nombre
de cas augmente
05 05 % la vaccination
pardon je vous laisse finir
non c'est bon je vous écoute oui je
disais la vaccination il faut qu'elle
soit mondiale il faut que ce soit pris
au niveau mondial la stratégie vaccinale
l'afrique du sud vous le dites à un taux
de vaccination assez bas faut-il
améliorer justement la politique
mondiale de vaccination selon vous
oui je pense que l'afrique en général se
sent isolé
non de vaccins arrivent en afrique en
général et au groupe plus bas que par
rapport aux pays d'afrique au puzzle de
l'europe des états unis et l'asie sans
des petits donc le taux de vaccination a
démarré beaucoup beaucoup plus tard chez
nous par rapport à chez vous et ce qui
n'est pas une bonne chose
ce pas une bonne chose d'effectivement
merci beaucoup de nous avoir répondu ce
matin alain et ça nous a de nous avoir
répondu on dit en direct de johannesburg
merci